Walsh, those things that go from the floor of the ceiling in physical security, we're
concerned with them.
We want to know what they're made out of.
The wall construction, in other words, what the wall is made out of, makes a big difference
as to how secure the wall is.
If you want a nice secure bank vault or a data center, you're probably not going to build
your wall at a regular stick and timber, stick and frame, you're going to build it out
of a secure concrete reinforced wall or something like that.
A question that often comes up on the exam that you should understand is that you want
the wall to go all the way to the real ceiling and all the way to the real floor.
What do we mean by that?
Well, in a lot of office buildings, it's very common to have what's called a false ceiling.
If you look up in your office, you'll probably see something just like this.
We've got these looks like panels.
You can push those panels out and you'll find that there's another 2, 3, 4 feet of
space between that drop ceiling and the actual real ceiling of the concrete floor above.
What you usually find up there is electrical wiring and HVAC piping and things like that.
The reason I'm mentioning this is that in a lot of office spaces, if you push up one
of those ceiling panels and you look over, if there's a wall in front of you and you push
up the ceiling panel, you can often see over into the next space because the wall doesn't
truly go to the actual ceiling, it just goes up to the drop ceiling.
If you want a good, secure area, if you have a higher valley area that you want to protect
access to, you've got to make sure that that wall actually truly extends all the way to
the true ceiling.
Within data centers, we very commonly have raised floors.
These floors will be 24, 36 inches off the ground, off of the true floor.
What's running underneath there?
You've got all your electrical cables and that's usually where you duct your cold air
for cooling the servers.
Again, if your floor only goes to the raised floor, someone could climb underneath and get
around.
You've got to make sure those walls go to the true ceiling and the true floor.
As part of this, we can monitor to see who's moving through a building.
This is the idea of intrusion detection systems within a building.
This is things like having motion detection sensors, having proper walls in place to
control access and thinking about things like ventilation shafts and so forth.
That's all part of intrusion detection within a building.